la mercedes 280 rouler très vite trouve
plus de 150 kilomètres heures selon
certains témoins le compteur lui se
serait bloqué aux alentours des 200
kilomètres heure mais les spécialistes
mentir est pour l'instant aucune
conclusion définitive il faudra attendre
la fin des expertises
l'élément nouveau lui est parvenue du
parquet de paris cet après midi
henri-paul le chauffeur qui travaillait
au ritz conduisait en état d'ébriété un
gramme 75 d'alcool dans le sang
au lieu des 0,5 toléré par la
législation française
le chauffeur aurait-il alors perdu tout
seul le contrôle de sa voiture
ou encore comme l'expliquent un témoin
l'avocat de la famille al-fayed
aurait-il été gêné par un motard qui
zigzaguait devant lui il a pensé qu'il
s'agissait d'un cortège officiel
et puis à pénétrant dans le tunnel de
l'alma
il a ensuite juste une moto qui se
trouvait devant le véhicule mercedes et
qui semblait et tenté d'empêcher sa
progression
seul trait vori jones garde du corps de
lady diana unique survivant de
l'accident pourraient confirmer ou non
cette hypothèse
une hypothèse que les enquêteurs
jugerait cependant peu probable
l'implication directe dans l'accident
des paparazzi pourrait même être écarté
leurs motos se serait trouvé au moins à
100 m derrière la voiture
reste alors la polémique sur l'attitude
des photographes
après l'accident des photographes une
main anonyme a déjà désigné comme
coupable
c'était moins un américain arrivé avant
les secours ont effectivement vu des
photographes autour de la voiture mais
il ne parle pas de gêne particulière
yahoo widgets s'y colle oui on a vu des
photographies qu'il faisait mais l'année
autour de la watch valley en prendre des
photos mais il est dans le titre
d'autres en revanche affirmé avoir vu
mitraillé la voiture les paparazzi
aurait-il continuer à prendre des photos
sans avoir essayé de porter secours
c'est sur cette notion de non assistance
à personne en danger qu'il pourrait être
poursuivi